the CEO of tick tock showed up to
Capitol Hill yesterday to persuade
lawmakers not to ban the social media
app and things did not go particularly
well
do you disagree with FBI director Ray
and NSA director nickersoni when they
said that the CCP could have the
capability to manipulate data and send
it to the United States do you disagree
with their statement the statement says
could so do you disagree with that
no I don't disagree with that okay so it
is possible that the CCP
under the auspices of bite dance which
is your parent company which you get
paid from has the ability to manipulate
content that is being shared with 130
million Americans yes Congressman I
watch this one make sure I'm
understanding all these questions
The Tick Tock CEO admitted that the
Chinese Communist party is able to
manipulate the extremely addictive
content warping the minds of 130 million
Americans every day
China can spread highly targeted
propaganda to half the country they can
also spy on us collecting countless data
to use against us
a big problem for our American
government which refers to spy on us and
spread propaganda and warp our minds
itself I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show we will get to
in just a moment my absolute favorite
moment from any legislative Committee
hearing in the entire history of
politics it might be my favorite
political moment that I've ever seen on
video
but before we get to that we've got to
get to tick tock because everyone is
reporting on The Tick Tock testimony as
though it were just absolutely terrible
a total failure and it it was always
going to be a little bit awkward because
the CCP does have a ton of access to
tick tock and can use tick tock to push
propaganda to half of the country
and when we say push propaganda and
manipulate content and weren't Minds
it's not exactly the same as when you're
Doom scrolling on Tick Tock the average
user of tick tock uses the app for a few
minutes a day the average user of of or
the average user of Twitter rather uses
it for a few minutes a day the average
user of tick tock uses it for something
like 56 minutes a day so it is highly
highly addictive you know if you've ever
been on it it's like crack just anywhere
you look it's another video with music
and dancing and lights and it's just so
totally engrossing so yes the CEO of
tick tock had to admit okay the CCP has
access here yes okay I wouldn't call it
spying but yeah we're kind of spying on
you okay fine but then
the CEO of tick tock came in to do
damage control that's Vanessa Papas
who said that she felt the whole hearing
was rooted in xenophobia
this is the key to the tick tock
testimony that people don't seem to be
picking up on the CEO wrote We are
committed to providing a safe secure
platform that Fosters an inclusive space
for our amazing diverse communities to
call home it's a shame today's
conversation felt rooted in xenophobia
thank you to our employees who worked
tirelessly to protect our platform and
community
this wasn't just a big flop accident oh
my gosh what was Tick Tock thinking
showing up to Capitol Hill oh no Tick
Tock knew the questions that they were
going to be asked Tick Tock knew that
the answers were going to be a little
bit awkward that was baked in
but what Tick Tock has done and I
suspect this will be successful
is they've now made an effort to reframe
the debate about banning Tick Tock the
idea of banning Tick Tock certainly from
government devices but from All American
devices was gaining a lot of steam
throughout the country it's a very
popular idea
and what Tick Tock has done is come in
now and say hold on if you want to ban
this Chinese spy app that sounds kind of
xenophobic you wouldn't want me to call
you a racist would you
and that won't persuade serious
Republicans with real National Security
concerns
but that might persuade a lot of
Democrats that might even persuade
people in the middle because the worst
thing to be called in America is racist
but what about the claim the claim that
this is xenophobic
yeah I guess so it's not phobic because
the fear is not irrational to have a
fear of the Chinese Communist Party
spying on you and pushing propaganda to
half your country that's not irrational
it's a very rational fear
but yes the fear comes from the fact
that these are foreigners doing it
so if that's what xenophobia means today
then call US xenophobic I guess that is
a fear
I pointed out at the top that the reason
that Facebook and Twitter and YouTube
and Google are so concerned about Tick
Tock is not because of privacy concerns
it's because of competition they don't
want to have to compete for eyeballs the
reason the government is so concerned
about the CCP spying on us is our own
government wants to spy on us our own
government wants to push propaganda to
us and and that's true I don't want the
kind of liberal propaganda that comes at
me from the government I don't want the
kind of mass spying on me that we see
from the United States government
but there actually is a difference
one's own government has much more of a
right to do these kinds of things than a
foreign government so we we should treat
these things differently and we should
treat them differently precisely because
one of them is foreign the others are
domestic
all of that said they can ban Tick Tock
they cannot ban Tick Tock I don't I
don't really care
I'm more interested now in reining in
Facebook
Twitter I guess we already have Elon
there so we'll put Twitter aside for a
second
YouTube Google
all the rest of it
those are the people spreading
propaganda and spying on us
that I'm more concerned with at the
moment but there's nothing wrong in
principle with treating Tick Tock
differently
these are different powers with
different cultures we're now told in the
United States that we have got to
respect other cultures never criticize
other cultures we Americans we are the
source of all the evil in the world and
so we need to be much more restrained
how dare you ever go into any of these
Avatar like civilizations that are
living in peace in harmony with nature
and we go in with our white culture and
our evil white capitalism or whatever
and we mess up we mess up the countries
so that has been the push largely from
the left to say stop interfering in
other places around the world you have
no right to do it one place that you see
this especially would be
colonialism in Africa well there's a new
law that just passed in Uganda that
confounds some of this liberal argument
we're going to talk about it when you
want to talk to your friends you got to
check out pure talk right now go to
puretalk.com use promo code Knowles do
not fall for the free phone deals from
Verizon ATT and T-Mobile it's just
another trick to lock you into a
long-term contract that will cost you a
fortune every month instead get a brand
new iPhone 12 from Pure Talk for just 12
a month no contract no interest you can
cancel or leave anytime Pure Talk uses
the same Nationwide networks as major
carriers so you will get the same
reliable coverage you're used to with a
range of affordable plans to choose from
you can find the perfect option for your
needs get unlimited talk text and plenty
of data for just thirty dollars a month
switch over to Pure Talk in as little as
10 minutes while keeping your phone and
your phone number through us-based
customer service team makes the switch
super easy frankly just having a
us-based customer service team is to me
a perfect reason this switch and they're
backing it up with 100 money back
guarantee go to puretalk.com enter promo
code Knolls save 50 off your first month
that is puretalk.com promo code Knowles
kwles Pure Talk is simply smarter
Wireless
for how many decades now have we heard
we need
to end colonialism in Africa we need to
end neo-colonialism in Africa
we colonialism was the worst thing that
ever happened and we need to let the
African nations govern themselves
Okay so we've started doing that now
we're letting the African nations govern
themselves
are the Liberals happy about that I
don't think so there's a headline here
from the guardian
Ugandan MPS pass Bill imposing death
penalty for homosexuality
that's African countries governing
themselves
to you and it's kind of funny that it's
the liberals who are the ones who say
this is outrageous America is so
terrible stop spreading your evil ideas
please
ugandans live as you like
very good we are going to kill all of
the homosexuals
not like that
um did you what so it's like that
wonderful video from the from the
African newscast you are gay why are you
gay the Liberals don't they can't
understand that because in their View
every single culture is liberal and
liberal in a 2023 kind of liberal way
every all the cultures are just the same
the only difference is some people have
more money and some people have less
money and some people get a little more
Sunshine some people get a little more
fog but you know we all basically agree
on everything that's not true
so the Liberals paradoxically are the
most inclined to impose their values on
the world but one of those values is not
imposing your values on the world so how
does one make sense of that the way
they're going to make sense of that is
they're probably going to go in and
reimpose their values
now for as far as I'm concerned the
death penalty is a little a little harsh
all right I'm all for standards and sort
of maintaining certain behaviors in the
Public Square but death penalty seems a
little strong but but if Uganda is going
to have self-determination this is what
they're going to do and there are
certain areas where African nations are
doing this
where I think a lot of American
conservatives would say hey African
nations can you come Run for the
legislature over here the libs are
constantly trying to push abortion on
Africa Africa says we don't want
abortion the libs are constantly trying
to push contraception on Africa the
Africans are saying we don't want
contraception we don't
we don't want that in position that's
the imposition of your culture
westerners
you think the imposition of your culture
is I don't know capitalism and racism
and this is now every country on earth
is extremely racist other than the West
okay that's you're not exporting racism
or anything like that what you're
exporting is the LGBT flag and condoms
and abortion and all the trappings of
liberalism
it's the new kind of colonial when the
libs protest colonialism you better
bring those protest signs and take a
look in the mirror speaking of cultural
differences
a Michigan College
has just announced a number of new
graduation ceremonies
this is Grand Valley State University
the Multicultural Affairs office over at
Grand Valley State has now announced
there will be graduation ceremonies or
celebrations
for black students
is the black graduation
Asian students
latinx students
talk about colonialism and
cultural uh overriding of of norms and
tradition latinx students
Native American students
lgbtqia plus students there's one group
of students I can't it's actually a
couple that I can't quite find on this
list
Where is the
where's the white student graduation are
the Multicultural Affairs officers said
that won't exist
and there's no where's the
I don't know the Christian or let's say
just broadly religious
student graduation maybe to counter the
more novel
uh sexual Revolution graduation no none
of that's there and
the response of many conservatives is
this is not going to go on forever
at a certain point white people are
going to get extremely angry about this
and they're going to push back and say
no you can't just you can't make US
second-class citizens we're not going to
tolerate that but I'm not I'm actually
not totally convinced I think the libs
probably will get away with it at least
for a very long time and they'll do that
because white people don't have a racial
consciousness
and it's one of the delightful things
about white people is we just don't
think about race that much we think that
race is
a relatively unimportant aspect of our
identity
you think about religion a lot we think
about culture a lot we think about
Nation we think about Affinity to
different
I don't know hobbies and vocations we
don't race is really really low on the
list
but for every other racial group in the
world it's much higher
according to Pew white racial
Consciousness is 15 for Asians Hispanics
and blacks it's over 50 percent for all
of them and for black people it's over
70 percent
so as long as that persists then you're
going to get you're going to get more of
these
sorts of graduation ceremonies
though there is there is a kind of
subtle
there is a a subtly Colonial or racist
undertone to this whole thing which is
oh there's the Latino graduation there's
the gay graduation there's the black
graduation
but the main graduation that's the white
graduation there is it's I don't think
the limbs are totally conscious of it
but it's it's the the same accident of
their uh invectives against colonialism
and racism that you see in their Affairs
in Africa speaking of wokeness at
schools there is some good news out of
higher education you remember a week or
two ago Stanford law had that horrific
display where a judge the fifth Circuit
Judge Kyle Duncan came to town and was
giving a lecture in these lunatic
students these students who obviously
should never been admitted certainly
should be expelled certainly should
never become lawyers they come out they
start screaming obscanities weird sexual
obscenities all sorts of four-letter
words that this guy to shut him up from
speaking at a federalist Society event
at that point a dean of diversity and
inclusion walks in takes the side of the
screaming banshee students
starts yelling at the judge and I said
at the time if the students aren't
expelled and the dean isn't fired then
were
we're just seeing empty talk
okay yes Stanford apologizes but talk is
cheap okay show me some action well
we're starting to see some action the
the dean of Stanford law school Jenny
Martinez doubled down on her support of
free speech in a memo on Wednesday
and then the diversity Dean Tyrion
Steinbach
joined the uh disruptors and and she has
been placed on leave
she's been placed on leaves she now just
just moments ago published an op-ed in
which she came out against Free Speech
she said that her job was to de-escalate
the situation not to defend Stanford's
Free Speech policy first of all your job
is to enforce the rules and standards of
the University broadly you're an
administrator at the at the University
that is that should be one of your jobs
now she's right in as much as her role
as dean of diversity is to undermine
everything the university stands for
that's what these administrators do
their job is to stir the pot they are
not doing their job if they're not
constantly stirring the pot undermining
the rules of the University undermining
The Pursuit Of Truth undermining
academic standards and and ginning up
racial grievance about nonsense and
imaginary problems so that is her job
she's been placed on leave now
being placed on leave is usually what
happens when your employers are hoping
that something will blow over
so we got to go further
I think she may have helped us go
further here because by publishing this
op-ed she's basically daring Stanford to
fire her
and Stanford should fire if Stanford
doesn't fire her now
it's going to look so so weak it's true
that firing her is going to lead all
sorts of lawsuits it's okay there are
plenty of good lawyers at Stanford law
I've been told go for it we've also got
some great news speaking of schools
on
on the education front we so rarely have
good news on the education front but
Florida has become the sixth state to
enact school choice into law that's
after West Virginia Arizona Iowa Utah
Arkansas now we've got Florida why is
Florida doing this well one because
Rhonda Santos is a very good governor
and he's obviously running for president
so he's gonna score as many wins on that
board as he can before he formally
announces but
what explains the push in all of these
other states why School choices become
more popular because Republicans have
been talking about school choice for
ever why is it now the the consensus
wisdom
is that the reason that school choice is
winning now is because during lockdown
the kids came home and the parents were
able to see what they were being taught
in schools because the the learning
started to take place on laptops and the
parents could be in the back of the room
and the parents were so shocked at what
the kids were being taught in schools
that this renewed and a push for a
school choice maybe that plays a role
into it I have a little bit of a
different take though
I think that that one of the big reasons
that school choice is winning now is
because
parents recognized
the possibility of Alternatives in
education
I think humans are creatures of habit
and we can get stuck in a rut and we can
lose our imagination and think that if
something is a certain way right now it
always has to be that way
and so yes parents saw that their kids
education was
even crazier than they previously
thought but they knew it was a little
bit crazy
the kids are coming home and talking
about all this weird stuff that
transgender and the Pan's gender and the
thank you ma'am gender and all the rest
of it so they know that it's like that
scene in in The Sopranos when AJ comes
home and he's talking to Anthony and
Carmella and he says America is a
terrible place and Columbus was a
genocidal maniac and then Tony starts
screaming at him parents know that their
kids are being taught nonsense in
schools
they didn't know there was an
alternative and then for two years the
kids were sitting at home
on their computers
parents were exploring homeschool pods
they were exploring certain private
education methods and they were they
were recognizing that the education was
not particularly high quality and they
said wow another option is available I
think if people just see that there are
choices if people just see that they're
not stuck in with whatever the libs hand
them
that that gives people a lot of
encouragement and courage is not only a
virtue but the prerequisite for all of
the other virtues push ahead we've got
six states here that means that we've
got
44 to go
we need to restore balance to our
education you need balance in your body
you need to check out balance of nature
right now go to balanceofnature.com use
promo code Knowles living a healthy
lifestyle is not always easy especially
when you are always on the go you need
simple manageable routines to make sure
you are getting the proper nutrition
every day which is why I'm a huge fan of
balance of nature balance of nature
fruits and veggies are a great way to
make sure you're getting essential
nutritional ingredients every single day
their capsules are packed with 100 whole
food that you can take at any time
balance of nature uses a cold vacuum
process that preserves the natural
phytonutrients in 16 whole fruits and 15
whole vegetables and encapsulates them
for easy consumption balance of nature
sent a bunch of their products to the
studio my only complaint is that those
Jackal animals at my studio just want to
rip them all away for themselves and not
leave any for little old me when you are
disciplined enough to take care of your
health you reap all kinds of benefits
more energy strong immune system less
fatigue better focus head on over right
now to balanceofnature.com use promo
code Knowles Kenneth w-les for 35 off
your first order as a preferred customer
that is balanceofnature.com promo code
Knowles for 35 off your first order
my favorite comment yesterday actually
does not come from the show my favorite
comment comes from the Democratic
socialists
of Purdue University so you know I'm I'm
in Indiana right now is it Purdue last
night there were hundreds and hundreds
of protesters there were
500 or more protesters at a separate
venue down the street where they were
performing a drag show it was maybe like
800 protesters or something but then
even just right outside the lecture hall
there were at least 300 protesters last
night screaming and shouting during my
whole speech luckily the the room was
relatively soundproof so we were able to
get get through it protesters holding up
all these sorts of signs kill yourself
Michael Knowles kill the fascists
Michael Knowles is a fascist now I did
the math there and you see if I am a
fascist
and they are holding up a sign that says
kill all the fascists that would appear
to be a call to kill me
there was no math major in college but I
mean screaming like banshees obscenities
trying to block people calling people
all sorts of terrible names they
obviously had tried to get the event
shut down previously and
then this is the quote that the young
Democratic socialists of America Purdue
gave to the college fix they said
presence of Michael Knowles
on a University campus should cause
embarrassment to anyone who values
intellectual honesty and free inquiry
presence of
a conflicting viewpoint
should embarrass anyone who wants free
inquiry I don't
just as coherent as everything else they
say right down to the suggestion that a
man
can really be
a woman
I now have to get to
speaking of Florida my absolute favorite
clip I've ever seen from any legislative
committee
hearing
I guess at this Committee hearing they
were hearing objections and commentary
from various constituents and so people
put their names forward to be called on
and then this legislator would read the
names that were that were put into the
hat to to be called on during the
committee
you might see where this is going
[Music]
it it
was like an episode of The Simpsons
Florida station of counties waves in
opposition Pamela Birch Ford to Florida
State Conference of NAACP branches waves
in opposition Anita dick
is an opponent
waves in opposition
Holden hiscock is also an opponent waves
in opposition
uh Jimmy only Jimmy
I have nothing to say about that I just
found it really really funny and I was I
was identifying as my eight-year-old
self when I heard that and I giggled
quite a lot and I always love when there
were moments of levity in politics it's
not the legislator's fault he's just
reading the names in front of him
to see more butts we got Seymour butts
ears for commentary on the bill that's
great
that's great I really like that and
everyone's so angry all the time in
politics it was killed this person and
not this Terror think of the children
and
when you get a Holden mccock or whatever
the whatever the name was that's really
that's really great most people are
angry like Jeffrey Marsh Jeffrey Marsh
who is this
super like the creepiest guy you ever
saw out of the weirdest horror movie
ever promoter of transgenderism
he like cast out of Central Casting to
be the Uber villain of transgenderism
Jeffrey Marsh
is
angry with his critics it's okay to be
angry
anger is often your body your mind your
Soul's way of telling you that you are
worth something
that other people are worth something
that Justice counts
for something
so no don't be afraid
don't be um
don't be afraid to show your anger
don't be afraid
it puts the lotion on its skin or else
it gets the hose again speaking of
transgender representation in cinema and
popular culture
what what of his point
his point is anger is really good
you should be angry use that anger
channel that anger Libs say this all the
time channel that anger take that you
don't usually hear a conservative say
this
because anger
999 times out of a thousand is going to
lead you in the wrong direction
Drew has this line he says anger is the
devil's cocaine
I'm not saying there is no place for
righteous anger
there is far a far greater place for
righteousness broadly
yes there can be a case for righteous
anger but most of the time that you are
getting angry you are falling into a
Temptation and you're falling into the
sin of Wrath and it's going to lead you
astray and you're going to feel
justified in doing it because your
enemies might really be as bad as you
think they are and the way that they
persecute you might really be as bad as
you think it is
but you are called to patience
you were called not to indulge in Wrath
that it's it's like when you punish a
child
if you want to punish your child or
spank your child or anything like that
what do they always tell you I'm such a
softy with my kids I gotta I gotta get I
gotta get tougher before I totally spoil
my kids but what do the people what do
the the Educators always tell you
what are the what does your grandma
always tell you well you don't don't
punish a child when you're angry
wait until you've calmed down if you're
dealing with a rogue employee like I'm
dealing with Mr Davies all the time you
know gallivanting around carousing doing
all sorts of nonsense when I'm going to
you know bring down the hammer you don't
do it when you're angry you because
you're going to lose your your rational
faculties you're going to lose control
one last button on the transgender issue
meant to get to this yesterday too uh
there's a letter
from the vice president of the United
States to Dylan Mulvaney
Dylan Mulvaney the most famous woman in
America
she writes with the the letterhead of
the vice president
dear Dylan I send you my warmest
readings as you celebrate your 365th day
of living authentically
thank you for courageously sharing your
story and your journey I appreciate your
continued advocacy for transgender
equality including during your visit to
the White House last year blah blah blah
blah blah sincerely Kamala Harris
authentically
yes yes
if there's one word that comes to mind
when I think of Dylan Mulvaney it is
authentic
of course he's not living authentically
he's living the opposite of
authentically
he is a man and he's pretending to be a
woman but furthermore there was a clip
that just came out of Dylan Mulvaney
before he dressed up like a woman on The
Price is Right and he was behaving in
exactly the same way he behaves and now
in a way that he says is how a woman
behaves very over the top very fopish
and attention-seeking
now is that authentic I don't know I
mean it's clearly performed it's
obviously very very conscious
but maybe he just is authentically an
attention seeker he's certainly very
theatrical he is he was a Broadway actor
the emphasis on authenticity
is a big
problem in our culture because the focus
on authenticity turns all of our
attention on ourselves say am I the
thing that I just did is that really me
is that really me or is was I doing
someone else I don't I don't know what
do I real what's my real desire am I
what's my true uh sexual inclination
what's my true fashion style what's my
true uh professional calling what's my
true what's my authentic what's my this
what's my that
and it's it it's a a Fool's errand to
think in that way because a man wrapped
up in himself makes a small package
indeed
especially because man is mimetic we we
grow we learn we are educated by
imitating others that's true of little
babies that's true of adults we imitate
the way that someone we admire speaks we
imitate the way that they think we
imitate the things that they read we
imitate the way that they dress we we
imitate
everything we imitate their desires we
desire certain things because they
desire those things
so
the the way to live in a flourishing way
is not to just look at yourself and then
imitate yourself in this infinitely
regressive way and recursive way until
you're talking about nothing at all it's
to look elsewhere say how did how do
they live that hey that that good person
over there I'm going to imitate that
person I'm going to live authentically
as that person or that even better
person or ultimately what you're trying
to do is imitate God it's this is the
idea of the imitation of Christ and this
is the idea of putting your focus all on
God and then
trying to behave that way what would
Jesus do if you do that you're going
you're not going to be living
authentically as yourself but
paradoxically you will be living most
authentically as yourself because you
were made in the image and likeness of
God and you were made to do good so do
it
let me ask you something speaking of God
what are you ruled by
is a good chance you are ruled by
something whether you know it or not
that's inevitable so that is what Jordan
Peterson is talking about in episode 10
of Exodus
I am less interested in the interior
person morally speaking than you are
then and probably any of you are and
it's largely I do believe because I come
from a behaviorist law based religion
we care how you act that's why we don't
have a claim that if you look at another
woman with lust it's as if you've
committed adultery with her I am as I
said yesterday I I thank God for
America's Christians and maimonidity
said if it weren't for Christians the
world wouldn't know about the Torah so
uh I'm a big Christian fan but obviously
Christianity and Judaism are not
identical religions uh and and we have
no equivalent that if you look upon
another woman with lust it's as if you
have committed adultery with your heart
there's only one way to commit adultery
in Judaism and it's with a different
organ and I'm not being cute I'm being
very realistic
in Exodus Jordan is joined by a group of
esteemed Scholars theologians artists
and my great friend Dennis Prager to
discuss one of those seminal books in
the Bible new episodes are coming online
every week exclusively for daily wire
Plus members join now at dailywire.com
subscribe to watch Exodus now finally
finally we have arrived at my favorite
time of the week
this mailbag is sponsored by pure talk
at puretalk.com select to plan enter
code Knowles to get 50 off your first
month
here we go take it away
Mr Knowles I have an awkward question
for you about masturbation of all things
I'm a married man in my 30s I have a
child and I just have to know is
masturbation without porn to sin I feel
very ashamed when I succumb to the
Natural urge to masturbate and I don't
know if that is because I've grown up
thinking it was sinful and I
psychologically am wired to feel that
way or if it truly is wrong of course so
much of the internet tells me to just
have at it and be guilt-free but I don't
know how to not have guilt and I get
jealous of those that say they have no
guilt
so a sincere thank you for any wisdom on
this matter
uh yes it's wrong and you shouldn't do
it
you feel guilt because that's your moral
conscience the people who say that they
don't have guilt have one dull to their
moral conscience and two are lying to
themselves and the way you know they're
lying to themselves is because of a
great bit of wisdom from that political
philosopher Norm Macdonald who said you
know and you're going into your room to
do that thing you know with yourself you
know and what do you do do you open up
the window shades really wide open and
you say hey everybody no you don't you
close the blinds you close the window
shades and you feel a shame people don't
talk about that sort of thing openly and
because it's degrading it's very very
degrading and it's obviously not what
your body was built for and your
sexuality was built for
things have a purpose the purpose of
this class not quite as good as a
leftist ears tumbler but the purpose of
it is actually to drink wine though I'm
not a lush quite that much I'm I'm
drinking coffee in the morning the
purpose of
the paper is for me to read the show the
purpose of my watch is to tell time the
purpose of the sweater is to keep me
warm purpose of my eyes is to see the
purpose of my mouth is to eat and to
taste and the purpose of some of those
other parts like the ones that that
Dennis Prager was talking about earlier
the purpose of that is for a woman not
for yourself so yeah that's wrong how do
you resist that obviously sex is a huge
driver for men in particular you're
married so I would encourage you to
have a conversation with your wife and
maybe say hey look you know I'm uh
I am so drawn to you that we need to
express that a little bit more for the
uh generation and education of children
and for the unity of the spouses and so
that I don't fall into this sin which is
obviously a sin okay keep going
hey Michael I've been thinking about the
possibility of impeaching Joe Biden and
I generally agree with you when you say
that it's not expedient for Republicans
at the moment to do so
but with all of the corruption that's
coming out about Biden's family and
Hunter and laptop and all that
if he were to be impeached
I feel like this would be a game changer
for the Republican field in 2024 because
it would set Ron DeSantis apart
as being someone among those three
people Ron DeSantis Donald Trump and Joe
Biden that has not been impeached when
the other two have
and you can't say that about Donald
Trump so do you think that an
impeachment of Joe Biden would
uh make a nomination of Ron DeSantis
more likely I'd love to hear your
thoughts thanks
Maybe
there are plenty of reasons why people
prefer Ron DeSantis to Trump
but I'm not sure that that would
necessarily be one of them
it might sway people who don't pay very
close attention to politics and just
hear talking point and the only guy who
hasn't been impeached but as impeachment
becomes nakedly political and not based
on the legal criteria that are outlined
in the Constitution for for impeachment
impeachment will will become a badge of
honor
the risk for DeSantis there is that
people will say wait this guy wasn't
even impeached oh he must not be in the
fight this guy hold on this this guy
hasn't irritated the libs enough that
they've impeached him over nothing yet I
don't know I'm a little skeptical of him
now whereas with Trump we know that both
of his impeachments were so preposterous
that it it made one think wow
if they're going after this guy so hard
based on nothing he must be right over
the Target so I I don't think it would
really affect the race much at all and I
think
if you if you want to boost DeSantis I
would just focus on his many other
virtues uh
I I think actually calling attention to
his relative cleanness is is a downside
for for DeSantis because you know
they're going to muddy him up the moment
that he becomes a genuine threat at the
national level they're going to muddy
him up terribly so so
who cares you know at that point why not
go with the candidate who's already had
his dirty laundry aired next question
Hey Big Mike it's Damaris from Arizona
and I have a presidential question for
you
I really enjoyed watching your path to
the presidency interviews and in
particular I took special note of Nikki
Haley's interview I don't really know
her and I appreciate your interview
because I feel like I'm a little more
informed about what she believes in
frankly I don't have anything against
her or her running but I'm a little
hesitant to back any female candidate
for presidency because I do think it
should still be a man's position I might
be a little old-fashioned my thinking
but that's just the way I think
I also like you think it's too early to
get fully behind one person in
particular so knowing that I've worded
my question very carefully could you
perhaps sway me or outline the potential
positives to a female presidency I look
forward to hearing your thoughts and
thank you for being the best host at the
daily wire
thank you so much Damaris thank you for
your very kind comments and for using my
true title Big Mike best nickname I've
ever had
you want me to outline all the
advantages of a woman president that
could be the topic of a book perhaps if
I wanted to revisit my my magnum opus I
know I'm joking I'm joking I
think that there could be some
advantages of a woman president
maybe but it it depends a little bit how
you view the presidency there have been
great female rulers in history
but they've tended to be monarchs
rather than
Prime Ministers or presidents the
president in the United States is weird
because he's a little bit Monarch and
he's a little bit prime minister in
other countries they divide that office
up so that the head of state the
president is mostly ceremonial and meant
to unite the country whereas the prime
minister is the efficient politician who
is driving at uh policy and and the day
day in and day out of government in the
UK they've got a king
who is dignified or supposed to be
dignified and he unites the country and
then they've got the Prime Minister
which is the efficient politician in the
U.S the president is both of those
things so you think of
some of the great Queen Victoria very
important and wonderful world later
Queen Elizabeth II totally beloved
Elizabeth the first for that matter
quite quite beloved Cleopatra quite
quite a prominent and important
politician
a woman would have an advantage of
attracting the Loyalty of men
in the way that you would have that
loyalty for your grandmother that Queen
Elizabeth I think certainly in her later
years was able to cultivate or a loyalty
like courtly love you know the the idea
that you would Pledge Your your loyalty
to the wife of a lord and and
because women are just so much more
sympathetic and men put women on a
pedestal that
that maybe could work there have been
some there's one example really of a
really tough as Nails
conservative efficient uh political
leader in recent times that would be
Margaret Thatcher so
you know sometimes women can twist the
knife a little bit better than men can
they can be cool as a cucumber and do it
okay but it's a rare woman who can do
that but otherwise uh no
I don't I I would not go to The Ballot
Box saying all right finally we got a
woman president that there are
advantages that women could have but it
would not would not really motivate me
okay next question
hello again Mr Knowles this is once
again slap my base and I have another
question I wanted you to express your
opinion on what are your thoughts on
citizens arrests or citizen Justice if
you will I started mulling over the idea
that citizens who are properly armed
know the difference between right and
wrong actually tend to produce more
results than just waiting and calling
for the police and it reduces fatalities
of good people but I wanted to
uh take a look at the possibility of the
negative consequences whereas if
somebody does not know the difference
between right and wrong but they think
that they're just to take out somebody
who disagrees with them I.E the libs if
you tell them that they can't use the
women's bathroom and then they drag you
out and they beat you to death because
of that then how would we Define what is
the actual definition of right and wrong
for this sort of thing even though we
all know what the difference between
right and wrong is thanks
no we we can
infer from the moral order and deduce
what what is right and what is wrong
using our moral conscience and that is
Guided by tradition by the inherited
wisdom by the civil law
we we can use our faculties of reason to
work through these questions
but you're saying what about In the Heat
of the Moment
we have a right to self-defense to
defend ourselves to
take down the immediate threat but in
the example that you've you've just
given
at the people who go into a woman's
bathroom
drag the guy out who's mostly just
minding his business then beat him to
death on the sidewalk they would not
just be defending themselves or
defending women they would be engaging
in an act of vigilantism and murder in
that case so vigilantism very very bad
to say that you have a right to
self-defense is is not to say that you
now have the right to go be a vigilante
and go find every bad guy like Batman
it's to say you have a right to stop the
threat and then allow the Civil
Authority
to come in and and do what it does but
you have to be restrained in that regard
and so I don't see any fear of that you
always have the right to defend yourself
that that just comes from the law of
self-preservation uh but but to go
further than that you have to give it up
to the Civil Authority even if the Civil
Authority is corrupt and stupid and lazy
and does all sorts of problems
as is often the case that that would be
how you protect against that and in the
long run how you have a better shot of
ensuring Justice today's fake headline
Friday I've got more mailbag questions
to get to we will get to that you will
help me
to pick the correct
or the fake headline rather out of the
five that Mr Davies is trying to stump
me on the only way to do it is to become
a member of the creme de La Creme not
here on YouTube just like a leech
sucking up all this free content without
parting with your hard-earned money so
that you can help me figure out which
headline is fake on Fridays no no
you've got to join that inner circle
La Crema
over at dailywire.com Knowles use code
Knowles for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
foreign